Have You Ever Seen The Experiment
there's a really interesting experiment
with monkeys and a banana and a water
spout have you ever seen this they put
five monkeys in a room and at the top of
the room there was a banana and when one
monkey tried to climb up to get the
banana they'd turn on the hose and
splash all the monkey's ice cold water
so the monkey will come back down and
wouldn't get the banana and when another
monkey would go to climb up they'd
Splash all the monkeys with ice cold
water and what would happen over time is
when a monkey went to climb the Rope to
get the banana the other monkeys would
jump and pull them down and hit and
teach them a lesson don't go for that
banana if you go for that banana we get
splash of War
then they'd swap one of the monkeys out
now there's a new monkey in the room who
doesn't know the game the new monkey
would attempt to climb and all four
monkeys would attack the monkey pulling
back down and kick his ass
he knows if he climbs the road to get
the banana he gets attacked he doesn't
know he gets splashed through water if
he doesn't if he gets him down he
doesn't know the game but he knows if I
try and climb they're gonna attack me
after a certain amount of weeks they
change another monkey and another monkey
Another Monkey over time you have five
brand new monkeys who have never been
splashed with water ever but nobody goes
to climb the Rope because if they do
they're attacked by all the other
monkeys nobody even knows why yeah
that's just how it works that's what
they're doing on a long enough time
scale to humanity there are already x
amount of people on the planet there's
already a population X percent who knows
what it is who ignore their own eyes and
repeat what they are told you can't say
that that's not what they're doing
because they're already successful with
x amount of the population they've begun
the seed is there
two percent three percent seven percent
who knows they've already proven they
can do it now it's just a matter of not
showing up and hammering the hammering
at home make sure they repeat in schools
children are young they believe things
are impressionable hammer it to the kids
especially put it in every Disney movie
give it to the kids all day long they
grow up sooner or later long enough time
frame that's it it's generational attack
do you think that's gonna work though
because uh let me maybe unpack the
question so uh uh I'm from Glendale I
went to Glendale High School and stalloy
right so yesterday a big fight broke out
in Glendale mass that it's all over the
news so the fight was over these parents
Armenian parents who were for four years
are like listen we don't mind if you're
gay but don't teach our four-year-olds
about transgender don't put these books
in finally yesterday big old brawl it's
all over the news they're fighting
Armenian parents are like we're not
going to tolerate this this is just not
going to happen to us right then you go
to YouTube YouTube comes back and says
hey uh starting such and such all the
videos that were put up about you know
the election and you know whether it was
fake election or not we're no longer
going to give a strike or take a those
videos down they can stay up there right
this is totally fine then you see a the
Surgeon General comes out the attorney I
don't know if you saw this one here he
comes out with an article saying new
Surgeon General advisory raises alarm
about the devastating impact of the
epidemic of loneliness and isolation in
the United States this is the same guy
that was part of the camp is now saying
hey our epidemic of loneliness and
isolation has been an underappreciated
Public Health crisis that has harmed
individuals and social health our
relationship our source of healing Etc
this is the same guy that said wait a
minute lockdown you know do this do that
so the more and more arguments are
coming out against even ESG I don't know
how close you follow ESG where why are
we doing this did you see how much
Target lost 10 billion dollars did you
see how much Bud Light Lost 25 12 this
is no longer working well if you want to
like even one of the insurance companies
I work with closely it's one of our
biggest one we work with yesterday I see
their post on Instagram well because of
pride month we're doing this I I know
the people in that company but they just
raised a few hundred million dollars one
of the companies they gave the money to
was one of these bigger guys the
Vanguard BlackRock and you know State
Street so when you take money from those
guys you have to you have to have a
certain ESG score but a lot of people
are now saying this is not a proven
formula that it works stop doing it so
do you think guys like you who are maybe
in business who are maybe in church
they're saying Pope what are you doing
what are you talking about who are maybe
in the Christian church or maybe in
different denominations they're in the
military sitting back saying I didn't
sign up for this so meaning successfully
do you think these guys will be able to
manipulate their agendas down
everybody's throat or there's going to
be certain people standing up well
certainly I'd like to believe that the
tide is Shifting and we're starting to
get some degree of Victory against the
Matrix the whole I do believe that the
public sentiment is Shifting however
the fight is long and it's very very
difficult because I agree with what
you're saying only a year ago I would
argue it completely and say it's
basically over I'm actually very
impressed with the back with the with
the ground we've taken back with common
sense
but these people operate so slowly it's
generational these attacks the attacks
we're suffering now were started in the
70s and 80s they take it over time and
yes it's fantastic that those parents
fought back against that school that's
fantastic but there's a whole bunch of
schools where they didn't and who knows
okay that particular book might be
removed a softer version will be
implemented next year maybe that book
will come back they have all the time in
the world all the money in the world and
they're they're insulated from these
things that's what's most scary you talk
about Vanguard and BlackRock and all
these companies what's actually scary
about it is the people who are making
these decisions are completely insulated
from the consequences of their decisions
they're in Switzerland they fly private
they don't care you think they care
about any of this crap they'll say I'll
do this oh this calls to Riot
they don't live there they're nowhere
near it they have nothing to do with it
when is the last time you've even seen a
politician do these people even exist
nothing to do with where they they
operate it's actually amazing when I was
in Dubai once I think it was about three
years ago I saw the leader of Dubai
walking through the mall I was like he's
a person and he just walks through the
mall I was so impressed imagine a
western leader walk into the mall never
never never in a million years it's just
pieces of paper private jet vanish all
these people are in charge of everything
don't even live in these communities I
do believe that yes we can win because I
don't think you can fight to the best of
your ability if all hope is lost I do
believe we're winning and taking ground
back absolutely and I believe that we're
doing that by purely telling the truth
what our eyes see or is what's real now
we're doing it in the name of God
because you're saying our meetings are
strictly religious I think God and
religion is one of the best ways you can
combat these things
however the fight is never ending
because they're never ending gonna try
and Implement you talk about ESG scores
it's garbage they put together that's
not going to end it's just gonna get
worse and worse and worse over time
and it's kind of unfortunate and it's
kind of upsetting that we still have
this system where the people can be
unhappy with something The Peasants can
Revolt to a degree
but does it even really matter at some
point you get to a point of power where
you don't care do you think it's
hopeless do you think like we're
inevitably
it's game over we're all gonna eat the
bugs and end up in FEMA camps or no I
don't think it'll be that extreme
um yeah but I don't know but I don't
I don't Direction I don't know maybe I'm
foolishly optimistic but I just don't
see the future of humanity being
enslaved no I don't think it's gonna go
that far because that's what he's going
to say because you know there was a
Department of Defense report that was
leaked in 2012 and they said like
basically the general public still has
no idea
to the degree of how much the government
is manipulating the course of Affairs
you know current cross planet however
they did notice that there is a growing
amount of people just not complying you
know because when you take God out of
the equation when you take religion when
you take you know order out of the
occasion you're just like yeah whatever
you could do whatever you want you could
be whatever you want those people are
going to be harder to control because
you're just like oh well you just told
me I could do whatever I want to do so
I'm just going to do whatever I want to
do and I would argue like what you and I
are doing completely independent you
know
employed people on our own right this
wasn't available 20 30 40 years ago so
he's like what Tate is saying there like
that you know in the 70s they were doing
this in the 80s they were doing this in
the 90s yeah because the number one
reason the elites beat the normal people
is because they're just more connected
and have a higher and more efficient way
of communication Beyond us but the
internet has kind of been the great
equalizer actually even with myself when
I think about it I thought this stuff
was all conspiracy theories a bit ago
even me like if you watch my old
reaction videos like I used to get
triggered by some stuff and like I did
get slowly red pilled over time but I
think like as people like we have
in innate like detector and
like an ability to know truth when we
see it and even though like women can be
easily propagated like I think it takes
strong men showing us what's true and
that's why the red pill Community
honestly is so necessary yeah yeah
absolutely I mean red pill listen
because I told Myron in 2019 like when
he was in my coaching group I I said
Myron I said mark my words the red pill
will go mainstream and the red pill is
so mainstream to the extent that it has
women like you that are female leaders
people like you people like Ali you know
Ali's doing more like don't be a whole
thing yeah you know you know like which
is good which is good but you even have
women now that are jumping on board with
this cause and because they also because
a lot of women reach out to me beautiful
women too like stunning women reach out
to me like innately they know like I
know what you guys are saying is the
truth and like I'm just so happy to find
a community that is like a breath of
fresh air in this psychotic world of
Lies well and that's do you know what I
realized because at first when I I
started like the first time I saw Kevin
Samuel so I was a huge fan of like he
was one of my favorite OG's of all time
and you know I I called him a douchebag
the first video I I did yeah yeah that I
watched of his because I thought he was
at the time but what I realized is it's
actually like we're just so used to
simps like we are so used to men telling
us what we want to hear that nobody
tells us the truth and that it may have
like this gut reaction where we don't
like what the men are saying and maybe
we have this gut reaction where it's a
bit harsh and like you know when you
guys are saying like don't marry single
mother like you know the first time I
was like well that's a bit harsh you
gotta marry somebody it's not that but
then you know you think about it and
you're like they're right this is how
men feel this is how men think and we
have never been told what men think and
the thing that makes you guys Heroes is
you're telling us the truth in a world
of of yes in a world of lies and it
might be harsh and we might not like it
but at the end of the day if you listen
long enough you know what they're saying
is true have you ever talked to the
angriest and most bitter Red Pill Man of
them all Aaron Clary no no I think I've
seen his tweets I recognize the name
listen Aaron Clary is a genius in his
own right I love Aaron Claire he's a
great guy and I hate to even give you
this compliment Aaron your Dirtbag I
know people are gonna watch you
um but even he said this he said sanity
is the future of all wealth
sanity and a world that's growingly
insane
being sane and having common sense is
the future of all wealth yeah as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible